[Music]
you know as I look out into the crowd I
just wish that the families of gun
violence in this city got this much
attention because that's who really
deserves the amount of attention that
we're giving to this particular incident
so this morning I come to you not only
as the superintendent of the Chicago
Police Department but also as a black
man who spent his entire life living in
the city of Chicago I know the racial
divide that exists here I know how hard
it's been for our city and our nation to
come together and I also know the
disparities and I know the history this
announcement today recognizes that
Empire actor justice Millette took
advantage of the pain and anger of
racism to promote his career I'm left
hanging my head and asking why why would
anyone especially an african-american
man use the symbolism of a noose to make
false accusations how could someone look
at the hatred and suffering associated
with that symbol and see an opportunity
to manipulate that symbol to further his
own public profile bogus police reports
calls real harm they do harm to every
legitimate victim who's in need of
support by police and investigators as
well as the citizens of this city and
I'm also angry I love the city of
Chicago and the Chicago Police
Department warts and all but this
publicity stunt was a scar that Chicago
didn't earn and certainly didn't deserve
its mahlet attempted to gain attention
by sending a false letter that relied on
racial homophobic and political language
when that didn't work it's gonna let
paid $3,500 to stage this attack and
drag Chicago's reputation through the
mud in the process and why
this stunt was orchestrated by some
Alette because he was dissatisfied with
his salary so he concocted a story about
being attacked I only hope that the
truth about what happened
receives the same amount of attention
that the hoax did it's hard to top that
so I'm not even gonna try
Jessie Smollett now faces a felony
charge for filing a false report
claiming that he was a victim this after
weeks of wasting the hard work of a
dozen detectives resources diverted from
actual victims so what's the lesson at
CNN all about lunch
Sean Hannity is gonna eat just a small
let's lunch every single second Tucker
Carlson is gonna eat just a small that's
lunch every single second resident up
the President of the United States is
gonna eat his lunch what about the five
we want to eat lunch - so that's lemons
concerned that the reaction to the crime
is worse than the crime itself notice
I'm not saying hoax a hoax removes the
media's complicity no it was a crime
aided and abetted by the activist press
who embraced their perfect victim
ignoring all those implausible details
so dawn no one is interested in eating
small it's lunch but we'll eat yours and
that of the whole consensus media who
need a lesson in restraint in resisting
its own activists 'ok confirmation bias
lemons made it no secret that he
believes Trump supporters are racist
which is how Smollett portrayed them so
forget Smollett he was just serving a
function for the thirsty press seeking
that story
Smollett an attention addict with an
anti-trump fever he read the room and
saw that it was going to be easy to fool
the media and he saw all of those
sympathizing friends like Don Lemon as
suckers they should be pissed off at him
but he couldn't fool the cops or most of
us so if your only lesson is that
Smollett will be used as fodder at this
network while missing the fact that he
played you then you're as hopeless as we
thought you should have been thrilled
that the demand for hate crime exceeds
the supply and that you don't means that
it'll probably happen again hey Emily
you were a prosecutor what are the legal
ramifications of this entire case lay it
out for us well
for the filing the false police report
he could face as we've heard up to three
years in prison and then a huge fine and
then for that letter you know there are
there are consequences to the huge
mechanism of responses that is put in
place when you file a false police
report and you allege a hate crime or
you send a letter with a threatening
letter to a corporation building that
then deploys a hazmat team etc so for
that he could face up to ten years in
prison but I want to point out what I
loved so much about the superintendent's
comments Eddie Johnson yep he brought it
back to the real world which is that
there are real world real world
consequences and the hubris to me that
emanates out of Hollywood where this
celebrity will take something so
painfully large such as the strife that
has plagued Chicago and this country in
terms of its racial divide and
historical consequences and symbolism of
that news to shine for his own selfish
gain because of a paycheck that to me is
I just loved at the speech by the
superintendent because I felt like he
brought it home to the real world he
said this isn't TV this is what happens
juanzi did he said he did it big day or
they claimed it was because he was just
dissatisfied with his paycheck do you
believe that I don't know what to
believe yeah that's what the chief said
the chief did what did you wait what
were your thoughts on that he said oh I
like the chief you know I mean and I
think that he was very clear that his in
part of his disappointment was as a
black man in seeing Smollett take
advantage of the racial tensions in
American society but again it's all
about him I wasn't about anybody else
but him I will say this when the chief
said he'd like to see more attention
paid to things like the shooting in
Chicago what else or especially to the
as much attention to the initial charge
as to the finding that this young man
lied about it
the Chiefs wrong all the analysis shows
that there's more attention now to the
idea that he lied because it's a
conspiracy issue it's a fraud issue it's
a celebrity gossip there's more attend
don't forget Donald Trump Donald Trump
has jumped in and said you know he was
wrong and and it fits in with Donald
Trump
acts on the media so all the Trump crowd
is celebrating this in a way that I know
they're just leaf they're vindicated no
they're not they're vindicated Google
said there was any renewed for the they
were accused there was a symbolic and
they were the symbolic accused no they
he said he put a red hat on one but that
wasn't the highest charge he also later
was they were white was the victim of
some kind of racial crime and again
there's so many racial crumbs we've seen
a spike in racial crimes in the country
yeah and he this guy's mullet is so
narcissistic that he is out of touch
with reality and the chief the chief
should no more media attention more
cameras at that Police Department today
than ever before
well I we can talk to the end of time
about your your misinterpretation of the
facts let's go to GMA and it's gets Mel
its own words before I get to Jesse why
do you think you were targeted I can
just assume I mean I come really really
hard against forty five I come really
really hard against his administration
and I don't hold my tongue if I had said
it was a Muslim or Mexican or someone
black I feel like the doubters would
have supported me a lot much more see
Jesse when I listen to him I see
somebody who knew how to play the media
cuz the the media could be that's the
language that the media understood if
you're an activist media right he framed
60 million Trump supporters yeah and the
media bought it hook line and sinker
one I think what the chief was saying
also is that he'd like to see that much
media attention when there's a shooting
or black on black violence or gang
activity in the southside of Chicago to
now small it makes reportedly from
400,000 to 1.1 million dollars a year 60
grand in episode I believe he does not
have any children which means he is
filthy rich so instead of trying to earn
more money working hard he perpetrated
this hoax and everything he accused
Donald Trump of he himself is guilty of
he is a liar
he is corrupt and he is greedy so just
let that sink in also real hate crimes
now are gonna be treated with more
skepticism unfortunately and that's what
the police chief said and I think that's
probably one of the biggest results of
this also how dumb does Robin Roberts
look right now when she went out there
didn't ask him any follow-up questions
and let him perform like that I bet you
which she had that back also think about
all the frame jobs and the conspiracy
theories which we've seen all it takes
is a little common sense you talked
about it yesterday there's a bunch of
Magha guys and a polar vortex in Chicago
hate crime in people okay
Cavanaugh in high school was he really
participating in drug fuelled orgies or
Covington let's see wait a second a 16
year old a hundred and fifteen pound kid
was confronting some adult like the Ku
Klux Klan and and now Donald Trump it
makes you suspicious of the entire
Russia investigation but Donald Trump is
a Russia Trump is a Russian asset only
you don't have any sort of doubt when
someone says that if you don't believe
that there's any sort of suspicion when
someone says Trump is a Russian asset
you're crazy and you're gonna fall for
another one of these so what about the
what about the u.s. landing on the moon
I think that calls this this calls it
into question Dana oh my god well of
things one so he makes $65,000 in
episode his bail was just set at
$100,000 so he's gonna post bail with a
week and a half worth of work no wonder
how like the AOC s of the world feel
about this filthy rich person being able
to walk away free because you know right
we need bail reform the other thing
though I really like what Matt Lewis I
had to write today I'm gonna excite him
because I couldn't say it better he
writes for The Daily Beast he said that
the desire for sympathy and the moral
authority that comes from being
victimized has replaced the desire for
admiration or respect for some act of
heroism it was like victim chic if you
are a victim then you were going to get
more attention and he knew that but I do
think it's kind of bizarre though but to
your point he was able to fool some in
the media not all remember there was
people on the Left who are frustrated
like GQ magazine wrote about the
reporters in this case saying how dare
they use the word allegedly yeah
that that was whitewashing the idea that
this was a hate crime when reporters
were just actually doing their job by
the way Jesse I think that with the
Robin Roberts thing we used the tape of
the interview I think that is an
indication that she actually got this
guy to say what he wanted to say and for
him that's part of the indictment of him
so he set himself up that's what I'm
saying so I don't think that's the
reporter well I think I would have asked
a few more follow-ups that's all I'm
saying no offense to Robin would have
quizzer on geography yes and anyway